sylvie vartan ou on vous présente parce
que je crois que c'est sont vos débuts
non sans vos débuts non ce n'est pas une
astuce publicitaires et sylvie vartan
la nouvelle vedette de la chanson du
twist et bien cette jeune lycéenne de 17
ans et que nous voyons sortir d'un des
grands lycées de paris
l'oca nous a paru assez exceptionnel
pour que nous vous le présentions et via
ses clients si vous nous racontez vous
met dans l'histoire histoire est très
simple j'ai eu une enfance tout à fait
banale j'ai suivi comme tout le monde
les cours ont glissé jusqu'au jour où
tout à fait par hasard j'ai commencé en
chante à chanter avec francky sort dans
vous n'avez jamais eu envie de chanter
de devenir chanteuse
oh non mon rêve c'était surtout de faire
du théâtre mais par le chante non ça me
fait pleurer dit et c'est une chance qui
est arrivé en pleine préparation de bach
parce que vous préparez votre premier
bar nuit et alors vous allez vous avez
décidé de continuer quand même
premièrement le bac et dans quelques
mois ça aurait été vraiment dommage de
laisser tomber et c'est quand même
indispensable pour quoi on a un point de
vue culturel et même pour une chanteuse
et un vous pensez que c'est lui la samba
oui lorsque on vous a proposé cet
engagement de la pièce que vous en avez
parlé oui c'est au nom n'y a que mes
meilleurs amis qui étaient dans la
confidence
lorsque vous voulez absolument pas de
considérer comme une bête curieuse non
parce que il ya un moyen extraordinaire
à ce que je suis mais coup en même temps
il n'y a rien d'extraordinaire ce que
vous soyez devenue une chanteuse
peut-être